joe biden continues to push forward
radical policy it's amazing to me how
much radical policy this guy continues
to push even though
it's just not making him popular he's
catering to the left wing and i i for
the life of me i will never understand
the political malpractice in which he is
currently engaged according to cnn joe
biden has now extended his pause on
student loan repayment through may 1st
why
through may 1st
it is now december 23rd through may 1st
so we're gonna go like another five six
months without people having to repay
their student loans for what reason
exactly
the current unemployed he's bragging
about it the current unemployment rate
in the country is 4.2 percent
people are back at work
people have savings because you blew
money into their pockets over the course
of the last two years but they don't
have to pay their their loans their
student loans back
why exactly
why as a person who paid back not only
my own student loans but also my wife's
student loans i'd like to ask why
please explain
really what is your logic here
biden said in a statement that because
of the ongoing covet 19 crisis people
can't pay back their student loans
really so people who generally have
unpaid student loans we're talking about
a 25 year old who ain't gonna die of
omicron and
almost certainly was not going to die of
delta
biden said given these considerations
today my administration is extending the
pause on federal student loan repayments
for an additional 90 days
through may 1 2022 as we manage the
ongoing pandemic and further strengthen
our economic recovery
meanwhile the department of education
will continue working with borrowers to
ensure they have the support they need
to transition smoothly back into
repayment and advance economic stability
for their own households and for our
nation
that reversal came less than two weeks
after the white house press secretary
gensake indicated the administration
would plan to restart federal student
loan payments in february
the possible extension was first
reported by politico borrower balances
have been frozen for two
years two years
some democrats want it longer right
elizabeth warren ayanna presley
chuck schumer elizabeth warren and
ayanna presley put out a statement
saying extending the pause will help
millions of americans make ends meet
especially as we overcome the oh macron
variant
but they want biden to take further
action and just simply cancel up to 50
grand of student loan debt per borrower
for the people who are the most highly
educated and thus likely the most high
income in the united states
makes perfect sense
just genius genius policy from this
administration of course by the way
nobody would ever engage in bad behavior
with all the money we've blown into the
system i mean it's not as though people
stole like 100 billion dollars in
coveted relief funds oh wait that's
exactly what happened according to cnbc
criminals have stolen close to 100
billion dollars in pandemic relief funds
according to the secret service
the stolen funds were diverted by
fraudsters from the small business
administration's paycheck protection
program economic injury disaster loan
program and another program set up to
dole out unemployment assistance funds
nationwide
only about 2.3 billion in stolen funds
have been recovered so far
so they lost 100 billion but the good
news is they found 2.3 billion dollars
in stolen funds which sounds like the
government they sound like they're
they're great at this
assistant special agent in charge roy
dodson said i've been in law enforcement
for over 29 years i've worked some
complex fraud investigations for 20 plus
years i've never seen anything at this
scale
he said there's no doubt the programs
were easily accessible online
that brings the opportunity for bad
actors to get into the mix it was
necessary to try to get those funds out
to people that were truly hurting
nobody's at fault well i feel like some
people are at fault when you lose a
hundred billion dollars
just randomly whoops
but but don't worry guys everything is
going great this administration they
just they know what they are doing they
are experts and because they are experts
you should listen to everything they
have to say and if you don't listen to
what they have to say and then you get
omicron it's because it's your fault you
see
it's cause it's your fault by the way
the law of unintended consequences
remains undefeated
you have to love this final story of our
broadcast year on the on the live
podcast
this is an amazing story a democratic
member of congress was carjacked and
robbed in philadelphia after backing
defund the police representative mary
gay scanlon represents pennsylvania's
fifth district carjacked and robbed at
gunpoint in south philadelphia in broad
daylight
so yeah uh yeah you couldn't see that
one coming at all
defund the police get carjacked
welcome to democratic policy literally
being mugged by reality well the
democrats in 2022 are going to be mugged
by reality on mass and it's going to be
beautiful to watch
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video